the western corner of the biggest island
in Fiji is one of the most fertile
places in the South Pacific the hot and
humid weather provides ideal conditions
for tropical fruit they're harvested
early in the morning before the sunrise
we had to come here the boys have to
read and the girls have to banking the
fruits so that that's our program every
day that program was devised by Levi
Tora in the past his clans fields never
yielded much so he researched which
fruit would be best suited to the
weather and soil conditions and likely
to sell he hit upon papayas
but organically grown ones he then
joined forces with a couple of young
local farmers and founded a collective
the land surrounding the village was
divided up and each of the collective's
members was allotted a share these are
the people who should get targeting you
just need some direction they need some
clear coordination they need some vision
and they need some discipline and that's
that's the environment that we provide
the organic farmers work together eat
together and learn together all of them
are supporting families in nearby
villages they're especially keen to see
their earnings benefit their younger
brothers and sisters I know that back in
the village we are come across lot of
difficulties and struggle so our
families and of their village will and
money from this papaya these days
there's more money in organic produce
first of all though the collective needs
to have its papaya certified as organic
and that's no easy task
third party controls could cost a farm
up to eight thousand euros a year which
is prohibitively high for the young
fruit farmers in Fiji but Levi Tora came
up with an alternative a participatory
guarantee systems also known as PG s
this involves the collective operating a
quality assurance system these days
participate or II guarantee systems are
officially recognized
organic certification in over 20
countries worldwide actual people on the
ground the people are getting their
hands dirty I actually get anything the
system for you forget about the guy in
the middle forgetting about the importer
of the distributor the guy at the end of
the end of the chain this is the guy
that's gonna guarantee the system the
farm himself the papaya farmers in Fiji
have laid out stringent guidelines for
themselves every day they pray together
for their fields and crops keziah Bui
Rua
makes careful notes documenting the
papayas rate of growth and yield every
two weeks the other farmers visit to
monitor her crops standards are high
five farmers have already had to leave
the Association karan mapu sua works for
poet comm an umbrella association for
organic farming in the Pacific region
she hopes that other parts of the region
will start using a participatory
guarantee system it's allowed a few
islands to switch completely to organic
farming which is a major boon to the
fragile ecosystem of the South Pacific
the rest is up to consumers when you
think about it our highest-level science
medicine are all peer reviews if you are
doing a scientific study it will be peer
reviewed so we trust that to science and
we trust that too medicine I think we
can also trust it to farmers not least
because it's effective Levite Ora has
good news for his team a wholesaler from
New Zealand has heard of their project
and wants to place an order